[Music]
and we are celebrating today
episode 300.
is that right can you believe it kelly
no i can't believe we've been allowed to
stay on air this long it's unbelievable
you haven't gotten us canceled yet i
have not got
i've gotten close
per the internets but we haven't yet
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
dalone's show
and we are celebrating today
i can't even believe this to be true
episode
300 is that right
i hope i hope you're putting a bunch of
sparkly things and whatever not like
sparkly things and we need like
explosions and rockets and things
because i have low self-esteem
300th episode
and i get
calls and letters and cards all the time
from folks who
[Music]
um
say they've been with us for every
single one which blows my mind i don't
even feel present on all 300 of them and
then some of y'all have just joined us
recently and we've gotten thousands and
thousands of new people that are joining
regularly i'm so grateful i can't even
believe it can you believe it kelly
no i can't believe we've been allowed to
stay on air this long i know
it's unbelievable you haven't gotten us
canceled yet i have not got
i've gotten close
per the internets but we haven't yet
i can't even believe it 300.
anyway way to go everybody so in honor
of 300
um we're gonna do
what are they called the kids call them
the amas amas they ask me anythings you
guys are sitting in letters and emails
and writing stuff and so uh jenna and
kelly the whole gang compiled these and
we'll jump into
the ama ask me anything by the way
we may do this a little more regularly
it's it's sad i i think that my
uh
advice in the calls is so great and
wonderful but people are like hey we
just do more amas and so there we go
um so let's jump into it do we need some
like
rock music or something
sarah's got us in post okay
finish that shootout yeah then you can
make some no smashing pumpkins though
question number one worst band ever
smashing pumpkins that's not even a
question i just asked myself anything
and that was the answer i gave
all right
so here we go question number one
what does your current morning routine
look like man people love the morning
routine question over and over and over
um
so if you remember back to the early
days my morning routine was like this
minute by minute it was super regimented
and had all these different components
to it and i would explain it to people
and they would look at me like i was
insane
yeah i was um
but it had some very specific components
to it and you do this for five minutes
and go do this for three minutes and it
was about an hour hour and a half long
and it was just a lot
and then work got busy i started
traveling all over the country and i was
trying to take this extensive elaborate
morning routine with me and then my kids
are getting older and
i marry all these things right and then
we moved out into the woods and i gotta
deal with the chickens in the morning
all the stuff just happens
so here and
there's me being honest and hopefully
this gives you some um peace about your
own life
in many ways i collapsed in on it um i
got so busy being on the road writing a
book getting it out
flying back so we could record shows and
then hitting the road again
um doing a lot of things all at the same
time and
i
folded in on myself i started to sleep
in an extra 30 minutes or an extra 45
minutes or i would cheat on my workout a
little bit or i would skip this or not
so
anyway man
i i got real mortal this year um i told
somebody about may i found my limit and
it's always good to find your limit when
you're maxing out or you're doing an
all-out sprint or you've done something
stupid in your marriage or your partner
has and you find your you find the
balance there i did so my current
morning routine looks like this um oh by
the way i learn new stuff
i learn new things um i'm kind of
annoying because i'm always trying to
read and figure out new things and get
new information so here's where it is
number one here's the things that do not
under any circumstance i don't budge on
these
number one is getting sunlight in the
morning and this comes from
andrew huberman's work out of stanford
um if you don't listen his podcast um he
should it's so good um it's long and
it's in-depth and he is a neuroscience
professor at
stanford in the medical school
um brilliant brilliant guy a lot of fun
but uh if you're into deep dives like
how the
neurological structures work and how the
hormones and molecular structures and
dopamine all works together that's a
great place to go but he's put out some
great work about the importance of
sunlight your night sleep
starts in the morning and so i don't
ever budge on that the second one is
working out movement um i still lift a
lot i've gotten into running a little
bit more and the big shift i've made is
wrecking
r-u-c-k-i-n-g um because of james the
great james i got a
uh goruck backpack which i love they're
not a sponsor i don't get any money off
that it's just the best there is there's
the top of the top at the top it's
expensive and it's worth every penny and
put weights in it and then head off and
so
this week i've done an hour ruck one
morning and i did a weight workout and
then this morning i did a long ruck so
um it's a great zone two workout the big
things i guess the big things that comes
to workout is this number one zone two
which is new i've added that in the past
year um because of peter tia's work
ultimately letting my mitochondria
rebuild let my body rest and at the same
time move um so it's a it's a workout
basically zone two is this you're going
and you can still have a full
conversation
but
um
you're going right so you're getting
after it pretty good but you can still
talk
i haven't figured how to do that on
running but i can do it on a bike i can
do it rucking and which is a really fast
paced walk with weights on your back
basically
um
so i have to have some movement in the
morning sometimes i get 15 minutes and
that's it sometimes i get 30 minutes
usually it's 45 minutes to an hour of
something
breakfast i've i don't fast anymore or i
do it very very infrequently um the data
on fasting has come back and
we can talk about that another show but
i eat breakfast every day now
which has been great for my energy
levels and my workout levels and all
that i do work out fasted but not for
any reason
um time with my kids and my wife i've
become much more uh we may do a whole
show on this one day i've become
obsessive about time
because it's a finite resource i can't
get any of it back and i can make all
the money in the world and sell the
books in the world and be a number one
best selling it
but the time still keeps ticking it's
just tick tick tick tick and so
um i'd it's worth it to not go do some
weird aerobic yoga exercise on top of my
weight workout in the front yard when
i'm rolling around and singing songs and
chanting i'd rather this morning i
played candy lane with my daughter and
by the way i destroyed her two games in
a row she needs to learn not to step to
this but i crushed her um in candyland
but i spent some time together it was
fun we laughed talk some talk some crap
so that was cool i'm trying to
accomplish one thing in the morning work
related
and
we can talk about this later
when it comes to social media man um
i'm trying to do one work thing just get
out of the way and sometimes that's five
minutes sometimes it's 30 minutes
sometimes it's review an article um
knock out a blog whatever it is i'm
trying to do one thing in the morning
um i've not been keeping up with my cold
tub
it's been about seven or eight maybe
nine months now um
most of that's just cause i've gotten
busy and i'm doing that time with other
things i still take cold showers every
day just because i feel i don't they
feel better but um let's talk about it
i've become a full-blown addict
100 addict i don't say this with pride
to
my my phone uh an addict addict addict
and um
i've got my social media on one phone
and i have my life on another phone
and so i've had to start turning my
phone off and leaving it places because
i simply i can't control it and i wish i
could do something to be like oh just do
i can't i just can't
i over the last five or six months have
started
finding myself in the middle of really
remarkable events when i'm at a concert
i'm hanging out with my wife i'm doing
something with my kids and i think
this would be a really great post for
instagram
and what that does is takes me out of
the moment with my kids and it takes me
out of my moment with my wife or i've
stopped focusing on the concert and
having a good time and i start thinking
about how i'm going to get some sort of
fake
virtue signal
look where i was look who i was with
look how cool i am because i am filling
the blank
look how whatever
and i got to stop
and so it was about a week ago i went
out of town and i forgot it i left it at
home
and it was incredible
because i was fully present and so um
i've actually invited my wife in to help
me with this but to create some really
remarkable boundaries we're leaving town
for a week probably not gonna take it
with me
and um
i just got to create some space
full-blown attic i can't stop i sit at
home and just scroll and scroll and
scroll and type and i want to respond
and do this
um
and i talk about all the time and it got
me and so i've got to create some robust
structures to back out of that um so all
i'll say about my morning routine no
more phones um before i get to work and
usually i'm leaving my social media
phone here at work if i was you and i
don't have two phones i would delete it
just delete it get rid of it get rid of
it
um gratitude journal's a thing i do all
the time and then i've added some
reading in the mornings sometimes if
it's not if i don't have a work
assignment i can crank out and then i'll
usually do some reading so that's my
morning takes about an hour and a half
to get up in the morning and get going
and get cranking
um what are my uh is that good what's
your morning routine kelly
um four four marble reds
black coffee
i ride the horse lay some bricks on the
road i'm
building and then i come to work
it's close to that
it's very close very close very close
now i try to get up and i usually do um
some bible reading in my prayer time you
would jesus louise you had to go there
did you
you asked
um and then it's usually
run around you've got teenagers at home
it's summer right now so luckily it's
they're not even awake before i leave
but during the school year it's getting
them up and ready and moving and then
remember remember three amigos yes
when he's like what would you do with
whatever a million dollars he's like i'd
buy all the cars and whatever and i'd
buy all this and that one guy's like i'd
build an orphanage
and to help lead underprivileged
children and they're like oh yeah we do
that too
so way to go kelly tomorrow ladies and
gentlemen my my morning routine is going
to shift to uh
just some quiet time me and the bible in
my journal
and then i don't journal oh you don't no
you don't want to know what's going on
in there no
i do
i try really hard to shove it all down i
don't want to write about it
i see every once in a while
on the show it's starting to make its
way out you're like nope nope nope all
right there we go morning morning
routine there we go
uh question number two
what are your i guess you kind of said
what are your current uh eating and
workout habits
um
lifting weights um
zone two
um check out if you wanna know more
about zone two google peter atia att ia
dr tia is one of the few medical
practitioners that i i highly highly
respect
um
and um talks a lot about zone two and
then rucking is the other big one i also
am big i mean i hunt a lot and i fish a
lot so i'm out in the woods walking and
moving all the time but those are the
three big workout habits
um i have picked up uh running again i
was a scholarship track athlete back in
the day and so that was a big deal to me
and i quit doing that and
um i start running again and i feel
great i love doing it um wears me out a
little bit i love it um and i'll be
adding um some yoga in the next few
weeks i need to start slowing down and
stop doing all this forward movement and
do some lateral movement too so i will
be doing some of that um eating
i've been working with dr norton with
lane
i've really really
upped up my protein stuff i cannot
recommend his carbon app enough i don't
get paid for that to say that um
c-a-r-b-o-n it's an app and it just
helps you track your calories helps you
track your macros which is your fats and
your carbohydrates and your protein but
up in my protein a lot i'm working on
the next six to nine months losing about
25 pounds maybe not 25 maybe 20.
and really leaning back out and
he's helping me with that but it's a
lot of protein and really watching my
calorie count lower carbohydrates but i
just do better on low carbohydrates and
my wife does great with high
carbohydrates about every body is
different
number three
uh what are you reading right now all
right so i'm
i broke this down into a couple of
buckets here
so i like to read things that
um are going to challenge me on social
issues
gender wars um
race uh sexuality
oh i like to
those are sociological right i like to
really say well i don't agree with this
house is hitting me i'm gonna talk to my
friends about this but i like to see
what the conversation is out there i
also intentionally lag
by about uh
two to three years on that and i do that
on purpose and in general not always but
usually i've always done that because
there's always a fervor of a moment and
then there's a bunch of authors that put
a bunch of stuff out and then everybody
gets all riled up about it and those
moments are never a time to have a hard
conversation and really get in and learn
something deep so i'm reading a lot of
the scholarship right now
on race stuff on
the impact of how racism has impacted
just the operational structure
of
how things work systematically how
gender's impacting the gender
conversations um and so i'm really
trying to get into some of that not get
into that i've been into that for 20
years but i'm just trying to read new
authors and really a lot of stuff i like
to read way on the edges um like what is
this expert saying what is this person
he calls himself an expert saying
and so
they're rarely stuff that i recommend
simply because i intentionally go after
the fringe stuff and see where where the
winds are blowing culturally
the second place i spend time is in the
what i call the literature if you will
and that's just nerdy science speak for
what are scientists saying so i've been
reading a lot about anxiety and grief um
working on another book
and i consider myself an expert in those
areas and i say that humbly but i know a
lot about those stuff and i've studied
those things and i went to got graduate
degrees um studying those things but i'm
always looking for new science and new
authors to challenge my views on things
and so
i like to
really go to combat with an author and
all circle things and be like yes nailed
it or i said it in my book better than
you did or totally disagree or whoa
never saw that coming that's incredible
um
so i do that um i have started reading
more on spirituality stuff i've kind of
put that down for a long time
and um
i've i'm a person of faith for those
people listen but it's on a trajectory
so it's very very different than many of
my friends who say that i'm a person of
faith and it moves and so i like to i'm
reading some new things on it
and then i just i i really am always
into fiction um there's been some great
literature about the importance of
reading fiction because it's processed
by different part of your brain and so
my son is all into science fiction
and so
i've in a way to
bond with him i've started listening to
more country music
which is why you've probably seen me
bring my dog to work and i've got a
cooler beer back here and an old pickup
truck and two out of three things i just
said are true
um
but i uh
listen to country music because he's all
into that and i am reading
uh
like great science fiction and dude
you're into it ben oh yeah oh yeah i
love it
what are you reading right now sci-fi
something of ghosts it's phenomenal okay
it narrows it down yeah uh i i don't
have to top my head but i love it
it's about
how am i gonna say it because people
will be like oh gosh dylan has gone off
the deep end i have but i'm kind of into
it it's awesome here's what i do love
though um my gateway drug was octavia
butler who i think is
the modern day prophet and she's one of
the best uh
science fiction writers ever
but it also science fiction tends to
serve a
prophetic voice in communities right so
they tend to be thinkers who are
thinking about how things could go wrong
or go right or dystopia or super
optimism or how things we think are
going to go and i just like reading
people who push the bounds and go oh
that could actually happen or what would
the steps be for that to actually happen
and then i'm reading a book right now
about a guy on a horse and a ghost or
attacking hopefully that doesn't come to
pass but
whoever knows right
um and so
yeah the next six months so i break up
my fiction into chunks um i went through
a horror fiction last year which was fun
um
all the good indians was my favorite um
that was that book was that was a trip
it was awesome that was my favorite one
in my horror phase and now i'm in my
science fiction phase having a good time
there maybe i'll get to a romance
i probably won't get to a roman section
um what are y'all reading right now
kelly you can't read ben what are you
reading right now
we're writing a fantasy book called the
trouble with peace joe amercrombie it's
very like game of thrones okay you know
dragons and stuff
it's more like grounded
but like medieval sort of like stuff you
know
swords
jenna what are you reading i am reading
where the crawdads thing in preparation
for the movie that's coming out
i'm so excited for that very cool it's
very good it's like a thriller yeah yeah
yeah that bookcase oh my god it's been
on for a while it's been out for a long
time but it's been one of those books
that like i've been wanting to read and
now that the movie is coming out i'm
like oh i've got to read it now okay
before i go see that i'm enjoying it oh
it's so good yeah okay it's so good okay
i do read a lot picture books very much
[Music]
i'm reading this book about a dragon and
a in a pigeon or best friends
i read i like you because you told me i
had to start reading fiction because i
never read it and now i do so i always
have a fiction book going and then a
non-fiction um
my i just finished um the seven husbands
of evelyn hugo which is kind of a
complete and total beach read not
normally my style but it was actually
enjoyable i'm watching you light up as
you talk about it it's not really my
thing but i loved every second of it it
was fun i mean it was you know a quick
fun read and now i've just started a
biography of george iii
lots of beheading in that one huh
not really that he was the king that
when
when america became independent oh okay
king george king george okay yes
so
i'm sure he didn't celebrate
independence day recently i i doubt it
wasn't a
big deal
for the royal family over there it's a
dark day for them very cool
[Music]
hey what's up delony here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried
and most of us associate burnout with
work but burnout can happen at any area
of our lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get ten
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com that's betterhelphelp.com
all right next question what's my
favorite non-mental health book um i
feel like i answer this every time maybe
it changes um number one of all time
my good friend back when i was in middle
school changed my life man he i don't
think he even knows his name's chris
lowe he's awesome guy man just an
incredible guy he um
gave me his copy of catcher in the rye
and that book kind of sent me on my way
and um
changed a lot the great book fight club
was great
and that's one of my favorites too
anything by chuck palahniuk guys um he's
out there and octavia butler the parable
of the sower series is just such a
profound work
um and i'll say this
all three of those books if you're
sitting here
um catching the rise real well i guess
probably not it was banned a long time
um i don't recommend anybody just run go
grab those those books
um they're tough sledding and
if you don't like swear words or
violence whatever they're for sure not
for you
but those are some books that have been
very very important for me that i love i
just like them
um
next question what is my dream vacation
destination
what's yours
kelly
i say northern england but i've already
been but i loved it so much i would love
to go back and do a
three or four week tour
of just strictly northern england and
scotland i had you pegged for northern
arkansas
that's a
that was incredible you can't
you can't flip me off today because
you're on camera and that's fantastic
what about you ben
i think new zealand for me oh man and
fantastic it's in the works at some
point oh it is yeah
we need the show to take off so we can
all yes we can all go to new zealand
field trip group trip i am for sure and
yes jenna where do you want to go uh i
would love to go to italy my ancestors
are from italy and there's a street the
my maiden name is in rome and i'd love
to go there and see it's probably
you know crappy street but i'd love to
see it which is so awesome
it's like all run down like uh way to go
family crush this one um yeah my new
zealand's on my list um sweden and
ireland europe i'd love to go hang out
there
i also have to say this and this is
super annoying to my poor sweet wife um
like travel's not
super my thing
i'm more of a creature of comfort and so
i like hunting and fishing in outdoor
trips and so
i went to northern arkansas last year i
had a great time hung out with some gu
somebody that i love and
um we had a great time and hung out in
the woods and
i don't see what i was going to say it's
going to be hilarious but i won't but so
yeah it's kind of i don't know it's kind
of low key for me i'm not very fun and
that's much to my wife's i'm that's
that's my back half of my life i want to
make that different
but anyway i don't know
is that annoying
it's annoying
well i love to i think there's such a
benefit to travel of course there is you
learn about other places and not just
like i want to go to europe bougie
travel like we're all talking about
there's benefit to go into places into
learning that we have it really good
here and that we are the top one percent
so there's benefit to travel to places
that aren't maybe on your dream
destination list my
mom's side of the family has a has a had
a profound impact in ghana um doing some
work with those communities i'm doing a
lot of work actually and my mom just
went she's 72 just her and her brother
and um sister went to ghana to
um they dedicated a hospital to my
grandmother and her grandma and my mom's
mom and listening to her my mom had to
make do the talks because it's a
matriarchal society so the first
daughter gets up and gives a speech it's
not the other way around and not the
paternal society and so she it just
walked walking through the poverty and
the things she saw yet the good you can
do with so little and it was it was a it
was an incredible eye-opening beautiful
trip and the people were so joyful and
loved so um yes there's a great value in
going
and i just want to go to bed
i just run so hard i just went to bed
but um that is that's on my list of i
need to get out of here and start going
to see some stuff
um
all right next question
this is a great question i actually
called my wife and asked if she sent
this in
um she did not but she did give me her
answers and so these answers are
directly from my wife question is
how does your
first of all
i don't i don't even know if this is
true is this true the question is how
does your wife deal with your highs and
lows
and your stun gun energy that's not true
that's super true
do i have highs and lows i think i do
do you want
me to be nice or do you want to really
no we always said we would tell the
truth on this show yes you have highs
and lows really yes i thought i was
pretty like pretty like a walking xanax
not so much not in any way shape or form
do i have stun gun i do have that i do
have that i'm a lot i'm a lot okay so
here we go
walking through this um there's a couple
of good things to talk about here
number one
i hear this on the road
and
things like man i wish my husband would
fill in the blink like you
or i wish my wife would ask me questions
like you
told this woman to ask her husband
questions i wish you would i wish my i
could be like right
so
i think it's important to know that like
living with me is hard and being married
to me is hard and i don't do that on
purpose um i just a lot i'm a lot
and so all the things like i read a lot
of books and i'm doing a lot of things
and i've got an intense morning routine
that there's that's one side of the
teeter-totter the other side of the
teeter-totters i'm a lot
and i get pretty focused on my routine
and i tend to read a book and i just
zone out i lose
consciousness i just i'm head out and so
um
it's my wife that
picks up a lot of that and or drives a
lot of that so the question how does
your wife deal with your highs and lows
and your stun gun energy
i think this applies across the board
anybody listening to this number one
nobody's perfect and i'm tough so
there's some good stuff and some tough
stuff right
so here's what her answers were number
one therapy that made me feel good
and really great friends and i will
caveat she's got some extraordinary
friends both locally and
nationally friends she's had for a long
long time and newer friends that she
meets with regularly
and i don't get my feelings hurt when
she chooses to tell them things that i
wish she would tell me
i don't get my feelings hurt when she
has to go tell them that john really
isn't picking up the weight here or
struggling she has to process things in
her marriage with her friends i don't
get my feelings hurt about that and i
used to
that's an important place for her and
it's not about me and whenever i get
people or make like i can't believe you
told his friends about that if you're
talking about intimate details of your
sex life or something don't do that
that's stupid
um but if you are
talking about like hey i'm really
struggling with my wife and you've got a
group of guys that you trust and that's
safe and aren't gonna be like yeah bro
but is well tell us more about that man
what's going on
it's really important and it's not about
her it's about me processing how i'm
relating to her and so i don't get my
feelings heard about it i'm glad that
she's got a place to go talk about us
and talk about me and talk about herself
and talk about she's processing things
um she said that she has worked very
hard to disconnect her responses
from my energy and that's really
important
she made a great statement she said your
energy your highs and your lows and your
stun gun energy
that's your issue not hers
and initially i was a lot and so she
would try to match my a lot and then
when i was low she would try to match
the low even if she's having a great day
now over the past few years she's
learned
she's worked really hard and it's pretty
amazing actually because it untethers me
too in a great way i'll come home really
kind of low
that doesn't mean that she has to have a
bad day
i can't be a jerk about it but i can say
man i had a rough day at work or this
happened or i really had a hard call out
to deal with or somebody was struggling
she can continue doing what she's doing
back i'm sorry that you experienced that
without it her taking that on that's
because that's not her job the other
side i can come home and be like oh
let's go do this
and she can say well we still have to
get this stuff done and this stuff done
because she doesn't have to wear that
energy either and so disconnecting has
been really important so i would
challenge everybody listening
where are you absorbing other people's
energy in your life and trying to make
it yours
and disconnecting yourself from that is
important or where is somebody trying to
force their energy onto you
i'm sad you got to be sad with me you
can't smile and still be sad or the
other way i'm in a great mood why are
you so sad well because i'm just happy
to be sad you can be in a great mood and
i can be sad and it doesn't mean we're
broken that means we're just having
different experiences
um
she's also
very even keel and you know you tend to
marry your opposite and um she's pretty
even keel and she gardens and she writes
and she doesn't go on every ride with me
meaning when i'm like it's all coming
down let's fill up the freezers she'll
say oh okay if you want to fill the
freezers up you're welcome to do that um
i'm not really going to home depot right
now to buy another freezer um i got some
stuff i'm gonna do but if you need to go
do that that's great
or if i'm like it's all great let's go
buy a bunch of what she's like let's
let's look at the budget let's don't go
buy a bunch of stuff right so all to say
is she doesn't go on all the rides with
me anymore
and um i don't go on the rides with her
and that allows us to
not use each other's energy to keep
stupid cycles running they tend to blow
themselves out pretty quick
um and she also said that she's not
codependent um my highs and lows don't
have to be her highs and lows and vice
versa i'll often also say to two both of
our horns we're not abusive to one
another i don't force her into my lows
or into my highs and vice versa
um she also is super hardcore about
routine
i run so hard um i just go and go and go
and go and go last night is a perfect
example
i thought i had been drugged i collapsed
at 7 15. p.m
like out out out
and we got two little kids and so what
she has learned is a when john collapses
which happens once every few months
um it's not because he doesn't want to
be plugged in it's not because he hates
me or the kids or doesn't care about my
feelings
and usually we'll have talked about on
thursday wednesday thursday friday i'm
going to need you full
full presence and i'll i can figure that
out
but when i collapse
um bedtimes are still gonna happen
because she's got this routine built in
or when she collapses i know bedtimes
are gonna happen
also when i come home and i'm like hey
let's have a water balloon fight on the
roof and then shave the dog and then
spray paint each other that'd be so fun
she's able to go with us
and the kids are like ah and then we're
gonna do bedtime and we're gonna do bath
and we're gonna do bedtime and the
routine is gonna help tether the family
and so there's some days that we kind of
bend the routine one way or a bit at the
other but
it stays put and so those are the ways
that she tells me she deals with my
highs and lows i didn't know i had any i
didn't know i had any i know that um how
do y'all deal with my highs and lows
it's a great question
you know that's something i'm still
figuring out
to be honest i had an admin one time at
one of the universities i worked at and
our desks backed up to each other and i
didn't know this but she said i use she
used to when people call back candy to
get a meeting and you go talk to him and
go see him right away
she said i knew by the music you were
listening to because i could hear it
through the wall like yeah today's not a
good day let's schedule this for
tomorrow and i didn't even know she's
like i just knew you well enough to know
this isn't going to be a good day for
the meeting will not be productive in
this person's favor let's we should
probably go i didn't know that was even
happening right
um one thing that i've had to do is
figure out is whatever your if it's a
low is it something that
that i can help with or that concerns
the show
you know and if not
then i can't take that on gotcha but you
do
i think we have mutual trust enough
where you can say hey you're thinking
about something else i need you here
right and then i can then that's about
being professional and like being a good
steward of the show right then you show
up and you smile and you get it going
right you get it done right i agree with
that what about when i'm i guess you can
tamp it down pretty well you're pretty
good at that
you can bring my energy down by just
looking at me with your kelly look huh
thanks
[Laughter]
ben
like you're relatively new to the board
what does it feel like
if i can be a lot
you know
i tend to be like a i'm sort of an
empath so i kind of feel
the highs of other people i kind of feel
the loads of other people
but i'm also like a very peacekeeping
type so i try not to
like externalize that so i try to make
everyone feel comfortable and stuff
so i just push it down whatever
craziness you're dealing with i just
push it down
just shove it down i want to pretend
it's not there and jenna you carry a
flask with you at all times oh yeah you
know that's what i'm known for around
here exactly just having a flashlight
thanks for getting hard things are
getting hard there's jenna yep drinking
it away
how do you handle it when i come in hot
i know i don't know i feel like maybe i
i i do one of two things i can either
match somebody's energy or i can do kind
of what ben does where i'm just like eh
whatever just push down just kind of
staying level headed neutral
depends on my mood i need some level
head around me yeah
that's usually pretty good
huh but i'm not mean though right ah i
don't try to be mean oh never okay
i would be mad at myself if i was mean
that made me sad
all right good
actually i'm super mean sarah just edits
it all out to make me look lovely
he abuses us constantly
ah
i love it
hey john deloney here and people i'm
getting fired up it's finally warmer
outside and it's starting to stay light
longer and you should be spending more
time outside going for a run playing
with your kids at the park or just doing
a bunch of yard work i know that i'm
doing all those things but when you're
running hard you must remember to
recharge your body with a good night's
sleep and that starts with a quality
mattress like a dream cloud
dream cloud's combination of gel memory
foam and coil technology keeps you
comfortable all night long and that
means you can go all out all day because
you're actually getting solid restful
sleep at night time right now dream
cloud is offering their biggest deal
ever exclusively for our listeners when
you buy a dream cloud mattress you get
499 dollars in sleep accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's 749 in
accessories and savings start getting
the rest your body needs visit
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress and 749
in savings today
all right let's see here
um next question
how do i handle screen time for my kids
all right here's the way we do screen
time in our house
um everybody does this differently this
is how we do it in our house and i will
say this this is based on
walking alongside
countless people
this is based on
an intensive reading in the literature
it's in based on conversations with
people in the inside of the tech
industry this is also based on my
individual children okay oh that's the
four ways we make decisions
uh my wife and i so
um how do i handle screens for my kids
number one
none of my kids i got one kid in middle
school i got one kid in elementary
school
no phones
no ipads
we do have two decommissioned phones
that just have the internet
for library books on um the digital
books that we get from our public
library
and if you didn't know you could do that
there's several apps you can just go to
public library get books on it's called
books on tape because i was born in the
14th century but you can get audio books
and they're free and you just get them
from your local library it's incredible
it's great and my kids are reading if
you will listening to book after book
after book after book
and it's phenomenal i love it um the
phones are decommissioned the internet's
been removed from them and we are hyper
about um they don't have the codes to
the phones and so to get if they get
locked out they've got to come to us to
get back in
it's annoying for us quite frankly i'd
be out working in the yard i'll be out
working on something and my kids are
working on a project and also they get
locked out of the phone and the
the book they're listening to stops they
got to come get us and i gotta punch in
the code it's worth it it's worth it um
the next thing is let's see what
everybody codes on everything so we got
whatever
you know apps we have to watch things
sometimes it's netflix hulu whatever
happens
we got codes on those things and
here's how we do screens
maybe they'll watch an episode or two
once a week um during the week
during the school year never i mean
we're like we're pretty pathological
about that because sleep is the most
important thing it's the summer time
right now so we'll say hey we can go
watch a couple episodes
um of yeah you pick one and you pick one
and they go watch them together
and
they're i mean they're like i don't know
jurassic
cartoon legos i don't know what they're
doing but they're they're cartoons of
some sort um
friday night we have movie and pizza
night and um
so it really is a family thing every
friday we get together and watch a movie
and
usually it's something that or always is
something we can all watch except
occasionally i'll watch you know
my son gets started watching cartoons
and so we'll watch some movie together
and then my wife and my daughter will
watch them together but
um
really the big thing is our house
doesn't revolve around screens and we've
like i got my kid my son a bow and arrow
we have colors everywhere we've got
instruments everywhere and we've got
places for them to go run and play we've
got dogs we've got chickens
our kids can never say we don't have
anything to do or we're bored and we've
tried to curate a world where their
their imagination can travel with them
wherever they'd like it to go
and we're
like
on a safety level my kid my son will
take the dogs and go play in the creek
and i don't i mean it's a waze from our
house i prefer that on a safety measure
than handing him an ipad and then
leaving the house and him being able to
travel down the
um rabbit hole of the internets with his
12 year old brain
so that's how we do screens in our house
ultimately it was less about the
restriction on the screens and more
about creating the world i i did
i think i've talked about here um
it's cost my son some things especially
in middle school that's how kids
communicate they text with one another
and there's a lot of isolation there and
there's been some hard conversations and
he's been right on a few things um my
wife and i saved up our money and bought
some
like a foosball table and an air hockey
tech a cheap air hockey table to give
the kids something else to do because i
had said you can't do this you can't do
this you can do this he's like what am i
supposed to do man and that was that was
a great critique of of me in my
parenting so
um we've had to
shift things the other way if i look at
the cost of an xbox i was able to do the
other things for about that price and so
it was just a matter of shifting
resources one way or another
so that's how we do screens in our house
and everybody does them differently and
i'm not here to judge you um i will
judge you on this way if
a screen has become a digital babysitter
in your house
it's a way for you to offload parenting
responsibility for an hour or two hours
to give a child unfettered access to the
internet
um
it's incredibly unsafe
in so many different ways
and i would challenge you to re-imagine
how your house house works i also know
there's people working for jobs and
they're exhausted and they're scared and
they're dealing with their own trauma
and this there's a space that i need to
have right now and i get that and i
honor that
make that a short-term solution not a
long-term solution make that a i'm gonna
let this ride for the next six months or
nine months while i am working really
hard to get me and my family from here
to here
so that we can create a world we can
engage one another
it's not something to carry shame about
it's something to be intentional about
so hopefully that helps
all right next question
what is my favorite turnstile song
turn style the hardcore band that also
has some
lo-fi jam they're just incredible
they're one of my favorite new bands
uh i i guess real thing
turn style love connection
they're awesome they're so good holiday
mystery anything from time and space or
glow on records there's a two just great
glow on is
probably my top 10 records of all time
and that's saying a lot it's a special
special uh record i'll also say uh
probably don't run out and buy it if
you're not into
hard rock music you're gonna get it and
be like what is this noise right if
you're into it if you're into hard
jamming music
it's they're they're just really really
good um and they're the nicest uh band
live like they were so kind to their
audience and they were always checking
in like y'all doing okay everybody doing
okay and then they get right back at it
and my buddy
blake broke a rib i mean it's pretty
pretty rough people getting after it
broke some ribs and
um but everyone's like everybody okay
are we cool i don't know they're just
lovely they're just great
um and along that do i have any favorite
new hardcore bands turn styles one of
them
here's the thing a lot of hardcore bands
have become either like
like uh
like weight lifter bands like
everybody's all jacked up like
like we just jumped out of a crossfit
gym and we're like crush either that
or
they're screaming and it's this
high-pitched like middle school kid
scream like
that and
neither of those do it for me it's just
like what are we doing man
so um i still like old hate breed i
think they're i mean they're kind of the
legends
my favorite of everybody is sick of it
all i love those guys they have they
kind of wink at the whole thing but
they're also like from new york but kind
of like where it's from
and um i love the singer's voice so sick
of it all still my favorite hardcore
band uh turnstile's just kind of taken
the genre and
changed it in a whole new direction but
um
that's kind of who i like
and what's the best punk metal concert
i've ever been to woof
a band called 30 foot fall was my
favorite um growing up they were
incredible
i'm gonna have to go with pantera and
white zombie
what a show that was
i was 19. and i still remember it that
was a show just to kind of
that was yeah it was in a basketball
arena and the entire floor like where if
you think about like where a basketball
group would play
the entire i mean a basketball group
what an idiot a basket
where a
professional basketball game would take
place with
professional basketball teams
playing playing exercise ball against
one another geez louise what happened to
me the whole the whole court was a mosh
pit and it was something else man it was
pretty wild but that was back in the day
man that was that was a fun show that
was probably that was probably the best
metal show i've ever been to
um
and then we'll follow up the last here
music bracket okay you want to play
let's do it all right
so
these are questions that you all sent in
which is so
not strange incredible i'm glad that
we're all eye to eye on this one all
right
we're gonna play a bracket game on who
wins okay
bracket one
mega death versus metallica
i mean come on i know but here's here's
the twist
for those of you who don't know if you
actually know anything about old metal
you know this because this is like part
of the folklore
dave mustaine who's one of our neighbors
he lives down the street over here
was the guitarist the lead guitarist in
metallica and then they infamously sent
him on and fired him and sent him on a
bus gave him a bus ticket and sent him
home before he realized it was happening
and they just continued on and then
metallica blew up and became metallica
he started another band called mega
death and so a lot of the early rift
writing a lot of the early playing a lot
of the early development of that medal
from slayer and anthrax and metallica
came from that one guy so he has he kind
of planted the seeds of that entire
genre
um and so when it comes to
seeing along this when it comes to just
that incredible down pick riffing from
james hatfield when it comes to albums
so i gotta go to the talica i've seen
them both live i think metallica's show
is great
mega the show is just like everybody
just doing this like
like just shaking their heads man
there's just like this long moppy curly
haired unbathed dude just like
just
shaking their heads like
metallica had more like fist pumping and
anthemy and
i don't know that's just my experience
so i'm gonna say they win and so then we
move to the next bracket which is the
winner which is metallica versus twisted
sister
what do you think kelly
twisted sister's fun and i love d snyder
i
but
when you're talking musicality
performance it's not even close it's not
even close yes yeah we're not gonna take
it like i've got that tattooed on my
chest just kidding i don't but that
would be so radical yeah i mean it's fun
and it is it's an astounding
it's such a place in my my history but
it's metallica exactly so clearly i'm
talking so the metallica versus def
leppard
uh i'll say this all i've seen def
leppard live they're great they're a
great live man their guitar players are
vivian campbell that they're incredible
um
they have great melodies they've sold a
bajillion records
and they are no metallica what do you
think
this was hard for me i still i'm going
to pick metallica
because i think that that
again when you're talking about the
music and the performance and the art of
it
but i am a hysteria what a record dude
80s animal rocker girl with big hair in
a
acid wash mini skirt i have photos of
that well i'm looking at that right now
in a box you also have huge hair and an
acid wash skirt on right now but and i
love music death lab but i've seen him a
number of times in concert they still
put on a great show so that that it's a
little heartbreaking for me to say
metallica on that but i'm i'm
gonna have to i'm so sorry joe and phil
and vince i know i know yeah i'm so
sorry and i meant that come on they have
a drummer with one freaking
and he's great and it's amazing he did a
great job he does great job and when you
see him in concert they have a camera
behind the drums and you get to watch
his they feed his feet it's incredible
yeah it's amazing yeah yeah he's he's
just an incredible musician but um yeah
i yeah
i gotta go with i gotta go with the talk
on that one
um and then
here's the the final drum roll please
winner versus so metallica versus guns
and roses
this is where i have to say god
surprises ha defend the position
thought it's so hard
and cause because we're talking
three and a half records i know and
that's it we are
and part of it is also
nostalgia for me it's it's what the
group meant to me
at the time what did they mean to you
kelly
they were one of
the first
you know
i'm
just a few years older than you but when
they first came out it's a lot lot older
than them no a few years a lot a few
years a lot
just a couple one of us has a walker go
ahead
i hate you
but they came out right as i started
high school and so it was um and i got
to see them in 1989. i saw them at the
height in 1989
right after um uh appetite for
destruction then i saw them again with
metallica
in 92
and
i just
they're the end all be all for me okay
but that is a hard choice because both
of those bands i still probably agree
that there's better musicality from
metallica
but if i'm talking the songs
that i want to listen to still i'm going
back to the appetite for distraction
and because it's really like it's really
one record it is it's appetizing versus
the whole catalog oh yeah i mean you're
not talking to user illusion one or two
or the spaghetti incident or any of that
you know or um
but it's patience was great but patience
is a great song right but um you know so
it's november rain and all that blah
blah blah blah blah blah
but i had to kill it yeah all the whole
club
i know you do but
but also um axel's range
vocally allows him to do more back in
the day he yeah he was he could get
there that allows him to do more head
phil's got a growl that just i just love
it but
but his range allows him to do more um
different types of songs and do a little
more because if axel has such an amazing
range
so i
i
love love so sonically
now we're getting into the weeds
everybody you can feel free to hit the
15 seconds push like
fast forward through this
sonically
my favorite it's my favorite guitar
sounds ever are off that appetite record
there's something about that old
marshall and the old gibsons and that
knock off gibson this last just but like
sonically it's it's a tone and a sound
that i still love
uh i think izzy's straddling probably
one of the best songwriters of my
generation and he opted out he just
disappeared he went away on purpose and
there's something like magical about
that like just to leave that band and
sam out
um
so there's something
like yes and mckagan is just the bass
player always one he was a bass player
who played the bass like a lead guitar
like the whole thing
um i just can't even compare that and
slash i mean slash slash slash yeah uh
i've seen but i've seen every guitarist
i saw van halen i saw dan back daryl i
saw steve i mean i've seen everybody joe
cetriani um the two guitarists that i've
seen live three guitarists that i've
seen live that
like i
my mouth fill up and i put my stuff down
i just watched them
john petrucci of dream theater was like
like i couldn't understand what he was
doing
slash
and then this is embarrassing to say
it's john mayer
i went there expecting a pop goofball
and that dude
like i i seen clapton i've seen them all
and that guy was playing and i was like
oh he's special like he's really really
good
um
and
but watching salat he's just something
else he feels it he sings through that
that
box of wood and strings something
special
no comparison to metallica as far as i'm
concerned in terms of longevity in terms
of
um their message all of it in terms of
how they do what they do their
relationship with their fans i i just
think they're they're yeah they're good
so i'm gonna go with them who do you who
you go with
these youngsters in here don't have a
clue ben's like
you know
that's not my era i don't even they're
probably all like who like blink 182 is
on your um oldies station
oh yeah i mean if you talk like 2000's
like screamo i can have a conversation
okay like real quick
under oath or thursday
under oath no question the used that was
a terrible answer unbelievable i cannot
i don't even know how you got it behind
that board
uh
really
yeah over-the-used
to be fair i don't really listen to the
use that much but to be fair
to be fair
all right well there's that
all right so you can't get those minutes
back in your life but when you come we
come back we're gonna talk about more
counsellory things and answer um
questions you guys had about your
relationships and your marriages and
therapy and more so stay with us we'll
be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future will walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloney.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back and
all right uh hey john yes do you
remember the question where we talked
about your kind of stun gun energy and
your highs and lows nope what are you
talking about kelly um
so we have been in here an hour and we
have not gotten through half the
questions
but we all have things that we have to
go do
so we're going to put out a ask me
anything that basically was what's my
morning routine and we're going to talk
about metallica metallica and hardcore
bands exactly and reading but it's the
questions people asked
okay so how about this
we're going to do a follow-up
with all these mental health questions
so we'll follow up with these amy
because they're good quest they're great
questions we'll do a lightning we'll do
another lightning round you love i love
lightning rounds we'll do another
lightning round and ask and answer those
questions
all right
so there you go everybody
if you ever wanted to know my opinions
on
reading
and cold tubs and hardcore bands in
metallica
you just got an hour of your life
if you're new to this show go listen to
another episode because they're great
too and we've got keep sending your
questions in i love them and we've got
some incredible questions like how do
you maintain intimacy when you have
small kids at home
um how do you keep dyi home projects
from taking over your marriage how do i
connect with my daughter-in-law we got
some great questions that we will catch
the next time around so listen i'm so
grateful you joined us for this um just
getting to know us a little bit better
and here's the important takeaway i want
you to take with you
every six months or so we do an ama and
you'll notice my morning routine changes
the books i'm reading changes why i'm
reading them changes
my life is about change and how i can do
things differently and how i can learn
new information so don't
make your morning routine exactly like
mine make sure you have a morning
routine don't make your diet and
exercise program exactly like mine make
sure you have a diet and exercise that
you're intentional about movement and
you're intention about your diet make
sure you're reading and learning new
things and being willing to say whoa
i've been doing that wrong for this long
i'm gonna do something different now i'm
gonna change this i'm gonna try this
make that a part of your life so that
when your politicians change your body
doesn't go ah it just goes
and then you can have some hard
conversations or when the weather
changes or when your plans change or
when your marriage changes when your
kids
you're practicing change right that's
just that's the way it's you can either
fight it or you can go with it right in
a pretty profound way so as we wrap up
today's show the 300th episode
way to go everybody cool in the gangs
the lyrics the song is celebration it
goes like this
i'm gonna read it
like johnny cashwood
yahoo
celebration yahoo
celebrate good times come on
let's celebrate
there's a party going on right here
a celebration to last throughout the
years i can't even do it for that long
so bring your good times and your
laughter too and we're going to
celebrate your party with you
it's the 300th episode party thank you
for being with us and we will catch you
at episode 301 stay tuned
coming up on the next episode i'm really
looking for advice on
how i can
my husband and i can best help our son
recently been convicted
of a federal crime it's dealing with
online
child pornography
one of the things i think holds back
parents and moments like this you really
get forced into
picking a side as you'll move forward i
want you to
work to hold all of this
and what i mean by that is this
there is no innocent player in child
pornography
and next thing we know it was sugar
toxin e coli
which produced into hus causing her
kidneys to fail
uh the next morning she coded for two
and a half hours no i'm going to ask you
a hard question and no it's not a kind
question but i want to be real direct
with you okay did you intentionally feed
your little girl something infected with
e coli with the intention of making her
sick
absolutely not
then this is not your fault